normalmente los campus como este en la
universidad estatal de bowie en maryland
son paraísos de tranquilidad torres de
marfil para la búsqueda del conocimiento
pero el lunes de este centro educativo
tuvo que cerrar como se anunció en redes
sociales recibieron una amenaza de bomba
en la universidad de bowe state no está
sola el lunes y martes colegios y
universidades que históricamente se
alzaron como bandera contra la
segregación también recibieron amenazas
si bien no se encontraron explosivos la
casa blanca dijo que el fbi estaba
investigando
estamos evaluando lo que creemos que es
el origen el razonamiento la motivación
detrás de esto agente del las amenazas
llegan en los primeros días de la
conmemoración del mes de la historia
afroamericana
esto mientras eeuu continúan lidiando
con la injusticia racial un aumento en
los grupos de supremacía blanca y
debates sobre la supresión de votantes
cada vez que los afro-americanos
comienzan a presionar por los derechos
presionan por el reconocimiento nuestras
instituciones han sido atacadas por
aquellos que buscan silenciar nuestras
voces
howard quizás la más conocida de las
universidades históricamente afro de
eeuu recibió múltiples amenazas el jefe
de policía expresó su alivio porque no
se encontraron bombas pero lamentó la
pérdida de los recursos de la
universidad y la carga mental
innecesaria que crean tales amenazas de
violencia